[Music]
a woman allegedly cut off her
boyfriend's penis after he threatened to
leak their sex tapes because she refused
to sleep with him
whoa a lot of threatening going on huh
all right no but actual penis was cut
off though that wasn't that was a threat
yeah that's what led to it you know yeah
I'm so happy I'm a a grower not a shower
because you if it's not growing you
can't even cut it that's true I can't
even grab it yeah good luck trying yeah
like try to grab my penis right here
it's like that yeah can't get a good
grip and grab it yeah but then what if
I'm what if what if he's like well you
gotta have sex with me and she goes okay
and she fluffs you up and then she goes
oh that's probably what happened oh damn
that was Lorena bobber story right yeah
you guys remember that story I think she
slipped it when he was sleeping yeah and
then she threw it yeah oh sorry there
was another story it might have also
been out of Canada or something like
that but like uh same thing as other
lady caught there's a long time ago lady
caught her husband cheating on her so
she like got all kinky tied as [__]
that's terrible got him got him a
wrecked and then put a hair curling uh
iron on it I
I don't I don't know about burnt it just
curled up like a pig's tail
it was the most beautiful
he's like whoa it actually works it just
looks gorgeous I'm impressed though that
it had the length to curl up like that
that's amazing it's like a Costco churro
the technology nowadays is crazy I know
like I think mine would only curl once
like two curls dude that's that's pretty
good three is like wow
so this 28 year old man was rushed to
the hospital after this attack that was
in North Sumatra Indonesia but do you
think he's still gonna release it now
because he goes you you [__] the sex
tape
with his dying breath but like you see
that's what my penis used to look like
that'd be the loophole it's not a sex
tape this is what I used to look like
before and after but you don't know if
people want to see your sex tape you
know what I mean like your sex tape may
not be that good that's true it might
just have really shaky terrible angles
you know you might have [__] stop yeah
your [__] style
what if that happens like [__] selfie
style that's kind of weird what if it
gets posted and then like it doesn't do
good numbers and she's like oh what the
[__] yeah she's like we gotta do another
one she sues for that yeah I don't like
my [__] style
well because we have a big like head to
toe mirror in our room yeah and when
we're having sex it looked in the mirror
and I was like oh I'll say this I'll say
this if you like watching
what did you see his own face my fun
style which is which is what what is
nothing but his butt cheeks I don't know
it's just is it the same as everyone
else's like Fast slow stop
hold on give me a second I just leave it
to the pros you know yeah yeah
how like amateurs like they don't know
how to film [__] right so what if his
sex tape was just him like [__] her
and all you see is nothing but his ass
cheeks and her legs just like barely out
now you're talking about she's like oh
no not my sex video and he goes I'm
gonna show it and he shows it and
everyone's laughing at him look at his
[__] whale trying to [__]
it is true though it's like uh it porn
is so different like in terms of what
the product will look like I'm gonna get
the angles bro you got to really know
your stuff with my ex we tried to film
like camcorder days oh so there's no way
it doesn't it does not exist today but
like we were like oh it's gonna be so
hot yeah and they wash it we're both
like but this is gross dude you need the
lighting you need all that it just looks
so bad yeah you gotta try really hard to
make it look good yeah you kind of have
to get through a few versions when I
took a picture of my girl she gets mad
at me she's like these pictures are
[__] terrible so like no just wear
regular pictures hey that's the same
idea yeah it's true so then yeah yeah
you really need a friend
yeah because otherwise you're gonna mess
up and be like do a selfie one and the
whole like 10 minutes is gonna be of
your face yeah yeah it's gonna be like
if you set it up it's just gonna be like
one angle so you really need that friend
because a friend can move around you
need like 10 teddy bears everywhere
right yeah
you could do Matrix style it's
unflattering for both people yeah yeah
you need a camera crew you gotta really
know your angles yeah especially if you
have no production skills yeah it's
tough dude so if you need us like just
let us know for me I'm not taking any
sex tape dude I'm like Bart I don't want
to watch myself [__] that'd be oh yeah I
don't know if I see that either do you
like your [__] style Anthony he of
course he does dude look how can you not
of course I'm a fan already I don't even
know what it looks like but I feel like
I have to go like this
[Laughter]
how many times have you tried that with
your wife honestly come on be honest it
doesn't work it doesn't work so how many
know how many times you try that though
this style Yeah Yeah by Anthony Lee
style oh Anthony that's another level
though I try but you know sometimes it's
like you watch NBA on TV right like oh I
can take off from half court and [__]
bang one out no way and then you did
your wife do the five killer words what
was that what are you doing yeah
it helps to imagine that you're Anthony
Lee though yeah oh yeah please stop okay
be honest though have you danced like
for your woman before like during or
like before I do think I do think it's
funny sometimes when you like add
musicality when you don't need to
because like sometimes if there is music
and you're just like it's weird to like
not thrust at the same BPM of a song I
think there's a there's a subconscious
feeling sometimes you got music playing
like if Sandstorm comes on
that's a bad word but do you make love
to music frequently
do you guys had a playlist no no not
frequently I feel like that's always
like a a fun experience like it's either
music happens to just be playing what do
you choose White Noise what
[Laughter]
we do waterfalls if you play it
backwards ASMR dolphin [__]
these you know r b you know some of that
nice what's your playlist my boy like
you should make a playlist yeah put it
on all boy bands yeah send it to me put
on that patreon or put it on he wants to
listen to Omarion
hey when on Mario's problems
Mama Said Knock You Out really I know
like Usher helps getting into the mood
but while I'm [__] all I hear is
Usher and I'm not hearing the girl
anymore and then I'm getting an
association of horniness to Usher oh
like to the male it's like a male dude
right the man's a male a male dude I'll
say this I've never not once made love
to music really not even one time really
not even once nope whoa
so you just like dead silence
are your lights on or lights off guy
both
okay
50 50. oh sometimes it's awesome it's
off but like actually no lights on which
one do you prefer lights on like lights
on but you you detest the idea of music
playing while you're having sex I think
we both do why because it goes to
commercials she wants to hear me go yeah
because Pandora commercials
you gotta buy the premium dude
huh
I'm not done is what I like to hear that
gets my rocks off
like you guys everything like they like
you know like I was talking about
dancing like if you dance during the
whole thing like you ever think like if
you dated someone famous and they were
famous for one thing whether it's
dancing singing or like a certain line
in a movie and you were dating them and
you were sleeping with them wouldn't you
want I don't know for me I would want
them to recreate that that's crazy that
thing you know like like let's say you
start dating a K-pop Star and she's
famous for this one dance
I'm sorry but I'd want her to do the
dance that's nice while having sex
if she could or before like as a warmer
as a warm-up speaking of that I have a
friend who did something similar he uh
he was dating a girl who was on The
Bachelorette
and um he [__] her with the video of
her denying all these guys because he
thought it would feel like awesome to
see her like rejecting all these dudes
on the show while he's having sex did he
like it after yeah did she like it I
don't know I don't know if she looks
probably not he played he had it ready
and he played it on the TV well they
were watching her like uh her old
episodes and he was like dude I want to
have sex with you while watching this oh
[__] what did you say cheesy yeah but
but he like specifically was like dude
it felt awesome
that kind of makes it like let's say you
get turned on by Daenerys Targaryen
right and then you're having sex with
Emilia Clark or whatever like
you wanna have sex with the nurse yeah
yeah
we wanted to [__] come in on a dragon
right yeah dude on the throne of it like
[__] flamethrower your ass and you
survive it yeah that's true yeah what's
that movie the documentary with Adam
Sandler where he plays a stand-up comic
he's a big movie star funny people funny
people and then he sleeps with with his
girl and he sits with Seth Coleman's
girl but he does his little catchphrase
for the girl like I would think like if
you're sleeping with someone famous if
that's what turned you on about them I
could see people right yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's true because that's one
thing because you know because guys I'm
not saying I'm a pervert but like guys
on General we're perverse if we if we
did a K-pop Star and you know that
there's one dance that she does but
you're dating her and what's her name
yeah ignine let's just make it up she
may or may not be from twice but let's
say like she does the dance and then
like then all of a sudden you're dating
her and she's doing the dance naked
and you're like that's bomb that's a
fantasy right yeah sure yeah that's
acceptable yeah that's weird no that's
not weird though you just up perverted
on camera it's like if you were if you
were [__] dating Xena Warrior
Princess yes back in there yeah you'd
want Gabrielle in the room
Gabrielle I forgot her name but what did
you want I want Kevin sword
outfit I want to get sliced by a shock
room no you want you water him now
but you want to leave the breast knife
Kevin sorby
that's his name isn't it
isn't he like a hardcore political guy
now yeah Kevin sorbet he Associates his
sexual desires with something he can
lick
[Music]
foreign